good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
one thing we've learned about mass
immigration over the past couple years
is that all good people support it
immigration is the ultimate moral litmus
test
when a caravan of poor migrants from the
third world shows up uninvited on your
doorstep
the decent among us step forward to
welcome them in that's commanded by the
moral code of cable news
and more importantly by the poem at the
bottom of the statue of liberty
only bigots and haters slam the door
that's they've been telling us in the
media now
for years cnn's jim acosta has made that
point repeatedly
well it has finally happened the caravan
has arrived
but here's the funny part it didn't
arrive in our country it arrived
in mexico in the border city of tijuana
just across the fence from san diego
the people of tijuana are mexican
citizens so by definition they are good
people much better than you are
they're more welcoming and compassionate
less selfish and
less american they must be thrilled by
the new arrivals
as immigrants their new honduran
neighbors will grow their economy and
add rich new diversity to their culture
that's what low-skilled immigrants
always do again a point that jim acosta
frequently makes
so are the people of tijuana grateful
for this caravan from honduras
fox's william elijah went there to find
out firsthand
here's what he discovered should this
caravan had been stopped at the
guatemala border
of course i agree with that 100 percent
it should have
your country have it to be beware of
these people
because they are people they are bad
people
because they don't belong here they're
just migrants but it's like the same
in the same case it's like when mexican
migrants going to the u.s
they're undocumented you know of
incidences
uh here in tijuana and in other cities
that some of these people that are
coming into these
with these caravans are committing
crimes this is not about racism
we don't dislike a certain group of
people because they're from a country
one country or another we uh are here
because our government
has not uh taken control of these what
we call invasion
whoa wait a second that's not the script
we expected
at all the migrants are disruptive they
quote don't belong here
some of them are criminals it sounds
like what they're saying in tijuana is
when honduras sends its people it's not
sending their best
and that's a racist statement obviously
we know that because donald trump said
something like that about mexico once
and the geniuses on cable news
never forgot it they're still talking
about that line years later
as evidence of trump's white supremacy
and yet here you have
non-white people in mexico saying pretty
much
exactly the same thing how can that be
let's check back with tijuana to make
sure we heard that right
[Applause]
donald trump was right wait how can
someone in mexico
say that everybody in mexico hates trump
he believes in borders
nobody in mexico believes in borders
they're better than that
well maybe that was just a lone
extremist talking some crazy person who
found a microphone and a tv camera
we better check with the elected mayor
of tijuana
if anyone can speak for the people of
that city he can
here's what the mayor had to say about
the
[Music]
an avalanche a tsunami note the
dehumanizing terms he uses if this were
a liberal arts college in america the
mayor might be suspended
for saying that he'd definitely be in
some kind of diversity reeducation class
by now
if he worked at google he'd be fired
instantly
but he's not a student or a tech drone
he's the mayor of tijuana
where people can still say what they
think without fear of being denounced by
don lamont on cnn as a white supremacist
so they do say what they think and in
tijuana what they think is that a
massive and abrupt demographic change is
destabilizing to a society no matter
what the color of the people involved
might be
it's particularly destabilizing if
you're not rich and most people in
tijuana are not rich
even in mexico they're wary of ignoring
the law completely
and treating borders like they don't
exist they know that doesn't end well
most people know that doesn't end well
the difference is in mexico they can say
that out loud
we could learn from that enrique enrique
acevedo was an anchor at univision
he was just in tijuana he joins us
tonight from miami florida enrique
thanks for coming on
thanks for having me tucker i'm confused
we just saw
a group of mexican citizens in tijuana
saying basically the same things that
president trump
says almost to the word endorsing trump
are they white supremacists well
you have to understand that unlike human
beings
intolerance hate and even racism throw
freely across borders and that's what
you saw in those interviews
they're not running for president
they're not running for president in the
united states either
they are part of a group of around 300
protesters in a city of 1.3 million
who like many others along the way uh
this caravan
are opposed to to their presence in
tijuana and
you know the overwhelming majority of
people in tijuana welcome immigrants
it's a city of immigrants
can i i'm sorry right you know because
it's a big city for sure can i ask you
hold on you just said that they're
racist
but they're latino spanish-speaking
latinos attacking other spanish-speaking
latinos so where's the racism
well we're not a monolithic community
tucker we have people from central
america from venezuela from colombia
different backgrounds
different ethnicities and yes racism
exists in mexico towards central
americans it's not new it's happened
through but how is history but i'm
confused how is it racist
when they go across mexico violence
extortion and racism
okay but i'm not quite sure how it's
racism if they appear to be of the same
race
but moreover they said and i think i'm
quoting one of the protesters
it's not about racism this is almost
exactly what he said we want our
government to enforce our borders which
is what a lot of people including me
say frequently in the united states
maybe
has it occurred to you maybe it's not
just racism maybe it's okay to want your
government to keep your border intact
i think we should stop framing this
debate about immigration in absolutes
good bad enforcing not enforcing the
border as you saw there and
as you can see is enforced there's
border security
through border patrol through military
uh you know
members and through things like drones
and
atvs and high tech surveillance
equipment so
we're enforcing the borders
which is not a crisis or an invasion
it's just a
okay no i know what they're talking
about so i know what i know the talking
points are what's so interesting about
these interviews
is that they seem to contradict the
talking points
so to the people of tijuana we both
agree they're probably not white
supremacists i think we can take that
as a matter of faith they seem to think
this is a crisis it's their city and by
the way their mayor
agrees with them i assume he's not a
racist either or maybe he is
do you think they have any i interviewed
a major last week and he
raised some of those statements he said
that all immigrants are welcome in
tijuana and that he didn't mean
any discrimination or harm to the people
who are part of the caravan
so you know in putting those i'm sure
you bullied him
as as most politically correct media
figures do but
before we get to him retracting his
statements under pressure from univision
can we just address the core question
which is do you think he has any
legitimate complaint does anybody whose
city is overwhelmed by people from
another country no no no no have any
legitimate complaint at all or is it
always bad exactly
i was just complaining that we framed
the debate on immigration on absolutes
of course he has a point you know the
city is overwhelmed by the presence of
these migrants and
governments you know all the governments
involved should understand this is a
humanitarian crisis
and start acting like it instead of just
having the security measures at the
border
you know again i've said this a thousand
times we can spend a little more in the
countries where these people are coming
from and make a huge difference at the
border
or we can we can keep spending billions
of taxpayers dollars at the board
so you figured out what's happening for
you figured out people are coming from
you
i'll actually give give you airtime
we're live right now you've figured out
how to fix honduras and make it such a
thriving country that no one wants to
leave
to raise gdp to american levels how
would you do it just really quick how
would you do that
no it's i'm not coming up with a new
idea we've done this before with usaid
and it's worked we just need more
resources
at the border it's because it's spending
a hundred billion dollars over the past
decade on border security we could have
used some of that money on programs that
usa
has said it's really which programs
let's get specific i'm giving you a
chance live on tv yes which program
specifically
would have made the economy of honduras
so strong that no one would want to
leave and come to the united states
so usaid for example is working on two
of the
communities with the highest murder rate
in honduras
throughout the last two or three years
with this program they've been able to
reduce violence there
and therefore reduce the amount of
people who were leaving that town
these are only two why do we have a
caravan of hondurans coming if the us
because violence is not the only factor
we have other factors so but i'm just
saying what's the problem i hear that a
lot
from dumb people i think don lemon said
that on cnn we should spend more money
in these countries
has there ever been a program that has
changed a country
in the third world that made it so
appealing that no one wanted to come the
united states i don't think there is a
program like that
but again absolutes no one it's
impossible to just have a program for
for everyone violence is a factor
poverty is a factor even climate now is
becoming a factor we saw a crew from the
weather channel
with the caravan they were you know
tracking the the journey of a group of
immigrants from honduras
where 90 of crops have collapsed
giancarlo's freighter correspondent was
telling me how
the u.n has declared honduras el
salvador or guatemala
uh a region with famine so what about
the people i feel sorry for the people
in the caravan
and i understand why they want to come
to the united states i love this country
i i appreciate their good deeds
and that's the great thing maybe what
about everybody
else i mean we should start worrying
when people don't want to come to the
united states
it's going to happen soon if we don't
get a real border so
because we'll be like honduras so why
would people want to move here i mean
honestly
honestly my question is what about the
people who live in the united states or
in this case who live in tijuana
do they have any legitimate reason
not to want they do have a legitimate
reason by all means of course
you understand that and we've discussed
this in the past undocumented
immigration
is not a desirable outcome for any of
the parties involved i'm glad you're
making
these people living in their homes and
the people who you don't have to be a
racist
against there are better ways more
humane compassionate and common sense
laws that we could have
instead of what we're doing with family
separation and these measures that
really don't make any difference i don't
i'm not going to accept blame for the
disaster that is central america
sorry enrique thank you though
appreciate it thank you tucker